do you want to share this time with me
Friday this breads been squashed in my
bag little bit yeah I love that you went
for white bread like you didn't you know
you didn't show trendy and go no none of
that none of that
I want some carbs that's all I want okay
if we're gonna do this Fanny Thank You
Brady I think we need to cut the
sandwich in half but that does leave me
with a bit of a quandary because how do
I know exactly what a half a sandwich is
because look you know you've got this
breads sort of lopping around there the
ham isn't exactly even you know how do
you how do you
if this sandwich is bit badly made as I
am prone to doing how can you work out
where halfway is defining half a
sandwich I want exactly half of this
slice only exactly half of the ham and
the Warren exactly half of that slice
does the cut have to be straight oh yeah
and only one cut and it doesn't matter
where the sandwiches I want it even if
it's like that but thankfully the ham
sandwich there can help us
so the ham sandwich theorem says that
when you have three objects in
three-dimensional space
you will be able to cut each of them
exactly in half using only one cut and
the best way to explain this is by
building up from just one slice let's
say that you want to cut this slice of
bread in half but let's imagine
someone's already come past and taking a
bit of a nibble off of it just so it's a
bit harder yeah okay okay
yeah now it's obviously less obvious Wes
Cutlass muck it up a little bit more
here we go
less obvious where to cut right we want
to get this exactly in half this this
slice of bread now if I hold the knife
here all of the bread is on this side of
the knife and if I move the knife over
there now all of the breads is on this
side of the knife so what that means is
that there must be some point in the
middle where exactly half of the bread
is on this side and half of the brailers
on that side crossover point exactly
exactly but that was me
holding the knife at this angle and
moving through that way it would also be
true if I heard the knife that way
or more difficult to give the ankles but
that way so any angle at which I hold
the knife I can guarantee that there's
going to be some point where half of the
bread is on either side regardless of
the fact that the bread is all kind of
messed up and Binny environments so
that's fine now let's imagine that we
add in our hand it's making a little bit
more difficult let's can fold the ham up
in a slightly awkward way we already
know that we can cut this slice of bread
here at any angle okay so what we can do
is we can pick a point on this bread
let's say like that where we know that
50% of the bread is on this side and 50%
is on that side but what you'll notice
is that all over the ham now in this
example is on this side of the knife but
because we know that we can cut this
bread at any angle you can rotate this
knife so that now all of the ham is on
this side which means that there must be
a point in the middle where exactly half
of the ham is on this side of the knife
and half on the other side there's one
magic line at least one magic line now
the third component this extra slice of
bread yarn Brady look at this delicious
sandwich I've made you can apply the
same principles it's slightly trickier
to explain this one but the idea is the
same except in this case you now have
the angle of the knife to play with as
well so you're so sweeping over turning
it around and rotating it that way in
that way there should be a way where you
can make a cut through all three
perfectly in half one small thing we
know for a fact that this line exists
the theory doesn't actually help you
find it very much
so as that who came up with this it was
originally suggested by steinhouse and
Bannock that's back from Bannock tarski
thing where you can rearrange a sphere
to make two spheres that look basically
the same as the original one did and but
then it was proved in the N dimensional
case by stone and Turkey don't to be a
lot of mathematical problems that center
around things that happen in lunch rooms
and tea be weird huh I know exactly yeah
you'd always think but maybe that was
the most productive part of a
mathematicians day see these five
circles on the screen do you think you
can draw a line through them from that
we'll divide them into two equal parts
with the same area and perimeter spoiler
alert
apparently the answer is yes and it uses
the ham sandwich problem that you just
watched a video about if you'd like to
find out more about this go to brilliant
org slash numberphile brilliant is a
website full of science and maths
quizzes and puzzles and things like that
that will help you not just see
mathematics and science in action but
really understand it all better now if
you've got a brilliant org slash
numberphile the first 314 viewers of
this video who do so it could get 20%
off brilliance premium package which is
where all the best stuff is it's really
worth a look
brilliant org slash numberphile and our
thanks to them for supporting this
episode they're really good just go and
have a look see what you think